[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramy
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am your host Jade
warshaw I joined by fellow co-host
author host of The Rachel crw show my
host co-host today Rachel Cruz Rachel
has been a little minute since we've
been on here together I know since
before 2023 that's right last year
that's crazy but give us a call the
number is 8825 5225 we'd be honored to
take your call in this new year so let's
go straight to the phone lines where
we've got Donovan in Atlanta Georgia
what's going on
Donovan hey uh so I have probably
$50,000 in student debt uh and rather
another six or seven in Consumer Debt
split between a credit card and like a
small car payment that we needed M um
and I'm looking to go to grad school for
clinical mental health counseling okay
uh but obviously I don't want to go
further into student debt to do that
right so how would you recommend I do
that while also doing the baby steps and
trying to get out of that well I do
think that the first thought here is is
going to grad school going to have the
return on investment that you're looking
for because it doesn't always so that'd
be the first thing that I'm thinking
about and then two yeah you you don't
want to continue to go into debt you
already have 50,000 um in student loan
debt so if you decide that it does
return on investment what would it look
like for you to pay your way and what
does it actually
cost okay yeah
so yeah Donan how old are you uh I'm 24
I have a child and a wife okay wonderful
and what are you doing now for work uh I
work at a local college and like it
gives me free rent
um but are you able to do the grad
school program there and get a
discount uh I am but it's not accredited
so it would be it would be very low Roi
okay going to a different one I hear you
what is the change it like salary-wise
and like option wise how does that
change for you getting your graduate
degree uh I think it would double my
potential earning but also I would pay
the grad program would probably be equal
to the amount that I would get a raise
for which so it would be about 30,000 of
a raise if I got my degree and I would
make $30,000 more dollars and how long
is the program like how long would it
take you to go through that uh about two
and a half years okay and how much are
you making now Donovan uh 30,000 but I
don't pay any rent okay and your uh and
your wife does she make anything is she
uh work uh 26 okay so 30 and okay okay
so yeah y'all are about 56,000 okay um
Donan here's my advice I feel like
sometimes the advice I just know you're
not going to like it and I feel like
that's going to be it honestly if I was
in your situation and I had a wife I had
a kid I had a dream out there for you it
is to go to grad school for some people
it's to start their own business for you
you can fill in the blank on what that
is to me you have to take care of the
necessary things financially and start
on we always say the firm Financial
Foundation where financially you are not
in a shaky place but when you have debt
Donovan you're in a shaky place you owe
someone something if something were to
happen you have to pay this debt back
but when you don't owe anyone anything
there is a level of Freedom there
there's a less stress there's options uh
you don't feel this urgency that oh my
gosh I have to do this this and this and
that starts to limit your options just
mentally so if I were you I would work
really hard I would uh be working nights
I would work some weekends I'd have have
your wife pick up an extra I mean I
would do whatever you could to get rid
of this
$56,000 which is going to take a lot but
you don't you don't have rent you
there's not there's some expenses you
don't have uh but it may take a year or
two to do that and then I would save up
some money on the side to be saving for
to be able to cash flow grad school
because what's going to happen Donovan
I'm telling you you're just 26 okay and
I or 24 and I know it feels like I know
what I want to do I need to keep
pressing forward in this but when you
just have patience and you and you wait
even if it's even if it's 3 years okay
and I know that's not that is not fun
but you get to be 27y old Donovan and
you're either saying get me this degree
I know this is exactly what I want to do
I have the money for it I'm not putting
myself in a bad place financially to do
it we're doing it wise in a wise way and
I start this path and I make 30 grand
more the raise it all happens and it's
great or 27-year-old Donovan wakes up
and he's like golly Things Are are
shifting we have another baby on the way
we actually want to move back home like
you know what I mean like like things
start happening in life that may cause
you to make different decisions and so
if I were you I think that I think the
safest wisest route is to slow down get
this debt paid off and then save up and
go through go through grad school listen
I'm right I'm right there with you I
don't think that you're going to
effectively cuz he said he was trying to
do the baby steps and I don't think you
can effectively do both because we're
talking about a lot of money $30,000
$15,000 a year that's what you would
have been putting towards the baby steps
and um do you see what I'm saying yeah
and something tells me um you know you
say hey I have the ability to double my
income it's $30,000 you and your wife
together can make 15 that's a th000
extra dollars a month between the two of
you if you make an extra thousand and
she makes an extra thousand that's
12,000 m a month between the two of you
put that to I mean you're almost there
does that make sense like you can
literally do that with any of these side
hustles which is not going to be forever
Jonathan and again and that advice would
be if somebody called and they wanted to
go and be a photographer fulltime and
travel the world I would say I would
clean this up first get some money to be
able to cash flow that dream like it's
it's one of those things it just has to
be in the right order and what happens
on of it when it's not in the right
order we get the call at 27-year-old
Donovan and there's a you know something
happens and and your wife has to stay
home you don't have the money you're in
the middle of grad school you want to be
able to finish but you can't you have
all this other Consumer Debt like it
start to just really really intensify
and if you can just slow down and have
some options I just think that that's
the wisest way that's a really good
point and sorry Donovan we're we're like
overloading you but the other I mean I
love it the more we talk about it the
more things just keep raising themselves
in my mind as like a possible thought
and there's another part to this where
when you've got a lot of you know you're
juggling a lot of things you got a lot
of balls in the air you do feel the
stress to to complete it because it's a
lot right if you if you try going to
school and you're doing this debt thing
at some point you're going to hit a
fatigue whether it's a mental fatigue or
a financial fatigue and then the option
of debt feels even more enticing because
it's like this is a quick fix if we can
hey we're just going to take out 10,000
in student loans and then we'll be able
to pay like that starts whispering to
you and I really don't want that Donan
if you have oh sorry Jade no that's okay
I was done and if you have you know um a
credible job at a college now I would
look the option would be totally okay if
you guys found another College you could
work for that has a grad program that
that is credible and you could go that
way and get a discount and maybe speed
this up more so maybe it's even a change
of job because you're in a great you
know line of line of work to be able to
get some kind of perk when it comes to
higher education so I would even do that
see if the if the school will pay for it
if you and your wife move in Dr John
Zone they did that they lived in the
dorms yes and he went through school and
all I mean that's what they did and so I
I would look at some other options that
could fast forward this plan too for you
Donovan uh but slow and steady it's
always the way to go I know that's right
and take advantage of the fact that he's
not paying rent like that's great that's
the biggest line item on everybody's
budget so to be able to take that money
and quickly you know put it towards a
Deb snowball come on somebody love it
Donovan you're making the right move
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
this is the Ramsey show my ho my name
today is Jade warshaw joined by Rachel
Cruz the phone lines are open so give us
a call the number is Triple 8 8255 225
the name change sometimes change man
listen it must be because my mind is not
it right in this moment we're here it's
Friday we've been on Christmas break man
I know it's it's been a hard one to gear
back up towards and let's be honest we
had a tax meeting before this wait did
tax Mee so my mind is like waking up all
right let's go to the phone lines Rachel
because I need a I need a I need a call
right now let's go to Caitlyn she's in
New York New York what's going on in
your world
Kaitlyn hi great to be talking to you um
I have a a interesting question I'm
looking for guidance in how to approach
moving to the next step with someone I'm
in a relationship um with and they're
maybe not on the same page with me
financially um we're very happy but I'm
sensing that there's a lot of guilt and
embarrassment around their finances um
what he has divulged is not the best
news and so you know I'm personally not
where I would like to be financially but
I'm very actively working towards my
goals my question is you know what
advice do you have in approaching him in
the right way but also like still
getting the information that I need to
know um which is like can he change his
habits does he actually want
to I love this conversation so what is
the information like has he told you his
numbers as far as like what he earns his
debt like has he been open to that
extent yes um not not very you know
enthusiastically I guess I could say um
sure again like I think there's a lot of
um maybe you know embarrassment or just
sort of um not not enthusiastic to share
what what he has so far but yes he I
think that's normal by the way yeah 100%
I mean that it was interesting I was the
one to first come forward and say like
hey I you know we've been together for
so long I'd like to move to the next
step but like I um almost three years oh
so yeah and um you know I would love to
move to the next step and move in with
him or you know move our lives forward
in that way and I have personally you
know a lot of debt and student loans and
so I wanted to be up front with him with
like what my situation is and what I'm
working towards um but I didn't get the
same amount of information from him so I
figured it maybe wasn't good and after
some you know follow-up conversations
that is that is correct so what he has
shared is like his income okay um he has
he's taken out a loan on his
401k um that was one thing that was like
a bit concerning to me um and then you
know how recently did he take out that
loan I believe a few years ago within
the last five years still what I'm
getting at what I'm getting at is I
think you do have to be delicate with
this conversation because I mean you've
got your own Financial mess over here
that you admit like listen I've got debt
I've got a mess to clean up and so he
does too so when you bring up that
conversation it's almost like um you've
got to be it is surrounded by like fear
and shame and guilt and all of those
things so it's almost like you being
very forthcoming with what you've done
and I did this and here's what my plan
is going forward and I'd probably start
asking questions around um his
philosophy with money and with debt and
you can kind of open that with like
listen you I don't have to tell you you
know I have this debt and I've just kind
of I think I'm done with debt like I
don't think I'm going to borrow money
anymore I've started listening to I
don't you know I don't know how much you
guys share as far as um what you're into
in podcasts and things like that but I
think it'd be hard to be dating someone
that you've been with for three years
and they don't kind of have a bead on
what your you know what your interests
are whether it be Hobbies or Finance or
whatever so it seems like it could be
pretty organic to bring up the
conversation of hey you know that
podcast I've been listening to I'm
really like starting to get into it and
maybe asking him more generalized money
philosophy questions first as opposed to
what do you plan on doing with this 401k
loan kind of thing does that make sense
yeah and Kaylin I would always and I
always want to know someone's um
motivation behind why they did what they
did CU for some people and we find this
all the time doing what we do you know
there's a just there is a lot of just
ignorance people don't know and so it's
like oh this is an option to take out a
loan I mean I I guess like they've never
even heard of another way how to live
and so there is something to be said
about once they have some information
kind of what Jade saying
then be able to say okay so what does
this look like now because the truth is
I'm like I mean Caitlyn I I would still
be in a relationship with somebody if
they had student loan debt but the key
is that they want out and they don't
want debt to be part of their life it's
a value system thing do you know what
I'm saying so like to me it's you know
Winston like when we when we were dating
he like had a credit card and and his
philosophy was like oh I'm going to use
all the rent and all the utilities on
the credit card and then and I'm like
well I I can't like
I literally can't if we I can't do that
it's not allowed and to him he was like
okay so my NE My Philosophy shifts to we
just pay cash and we don't have a credit
score and we don't need a credit score
and okay like it like it all just kind
of made sense do that make and I know we
were young and you're probably way more
s in your ways Caitlyn and so is your
your boyfriend but the point is it is a
value system conversation at that point
what do we value and out of your value
system is where money becomes a tool cuz
money is just a tool it's just a tool to
live your life and you want to be able
live your life in a pretty similar way
or you're going to continue to or you
will butt heads if you guys continue a
relationship and open up the store so
yeah for me that would be my um my
number one and I think the empathy route
like what Jade is saying is so true
because you're not perfect Kaitlin I'm
not perfect Jade's not perfect none of
us are but I think the key is like hey
you know and maybe he is probably
feeling a lot of guilt and shame and the
and the truth is Caitlyn he's probably
not happy with where he is financially
right so then it's like okay so we have
to do something different and do you
want to do this together not combining
money but hey should we start this
journey we each have our own debt
snowball like what does this look like
to become free and talk about your why
Caitlyn why do you want to be debt free
is debt you know are you losing sleep at
night is it stressful do you have to
stay in a job you hate because of it
like like it's those kind of
conversations to have it's not just like
what Jade said the 401K loan you know
there's so much under that too to be
clear Caitlyn um and Rachel I think you
would agree with this these are this is
a series of conversations over time um
uh maybe some relationships you can have
that one conversation and it's like all
right we we we it's settled but I I mean
I can tell you with Sam and I these
conversations were months and like
depending on the level of guilt that's
there or shame these are conversations
that you're just looking for um a little
bit of forward movement with each with
each conversation like hey he he seemed
a little bit more open this time or hey
he seemed like he divulged a little bit
more or this time when I brought it up
he didn't go you know like you're
looking for that little um those little
steps forward that you're like okay
their mind is open and I can see that
he's trying his best but if you're
seeing um no forward movement if it
truly doesn't look like like look he's
not interested I bring this up and every
time it's like you know okay you know
but does that make sense it may not be
something that you get done in two date
night dinners you know what I'm saying
for sure and definitely I haven't been
met with like a resistance to talk about
it and it's progressing so that's like
really great to hear that it is
something that has to take time um I
just wanted to like hear your
perspective because I'm only still
understanding how much of like the
psychology of my behaviors has led me to
this and exactly what you just said of
like it's a value conversation where I
just want to make sure I ask the right
questions and we have the right
conversations to like make sure we're on
the same page like we do look at money
the same way and you know if we were to
move forward with making financial
decisions together like do we have the
right tools to kind of explore like what
what our thoughts are together yes yeah
and Caitlyn just um and know this too
because I'm such the spender in our
marriage my husband's the saver Winston
has like four spreadsheets in Excel and
every dollar he has all this stuff and I
don't even though I do this for a living
he is way more of that nerd so also hear
me say he
there there may be a sense of him that
is just naturally a free spirit and that
is who he is too like I don't want
everyone to think that everyone has to
be obsessed with money and can't wait to
talk about 401ks all the time and it's
so exciting about the new tax code like
like that that may not be exciting to
everyone and that's okay too so I think
it's it's the bigger value system that
together in a relationship we are moving
in the same direction with our lives and
you could plug in you know family you
can plug in spirituality you can plug in
all this stuff and it's just a healthy
balanced relationship and money is a
piece of that love that it is important
though to know when you hit your
non-negotiable mark let me just throw
that out there this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at CH Ministry .org
[Music]
budget all right everybody you're
listening to the Ramsey Show I'm your
co-host Jade warshaw joined by Rachel
Cruz and during the break we were
talking about non-negotiables
and so many of us face this whether you
are dating someone and you know you have
to bring up those conversations Rachel
about money about you know religious
views possibly political views like
there's all these tough conversations to
have and when do you know when you're
dating somebody when you get to that
point that's like okay this is I've hit
my point right like we talked to
somebody who was in a relationship for 3
years and it's like okay maybe now's the
time to start looking at this talking
about this but it's hard to know
especially if you might see a little bit
of progress and you're like yes this is
progress maybe we're going on the right
direction but what would you say Rachel
is let's let's let's call out some red
flags of if you see this this might be
pump the brakes MoneyWise I was like I
don't know if I'm not a marriage
therapist I don't know no I'm talking
about finances yes um would
say I always pump the brakes with people
that feel like they have all the
answers like when it's this idea that
like I I I don't have any more learning
to do oh like I'm kind of just stuck in
my this is it I'm good and you're like
you don't want to grow or stretch or
like hear something different like to me
in life right now that feels so prideful
so with money and we get this call a lot
with people that as we're talking about
non-negotiable so I guess there was a
little bit other side of this but this
idea that you know we we talk and
they're like well you know he just tells
me like he does want to talk about it
he's not going to talk about it or she
she won't even she won't even enter the
discussion I'm like that's exhausting
like that's exhausting so you can have
your non-negotiables but be but be
humble about it it's the spirit that you
bring to it um well let me be Devil's
Advocate because there's somebody
listening in their car and they're like
listen I'm the one who my spouse keeps
talking to me about Ramsey this Ramsay
that and whenever I try to tell her my
views on why I want to keep my mortgage
payment and invest it instead she's so
close minded like she doesn't want to
hear she feels like she's found this
plan and that's it like there's no like
let's talk about it from that point of
view so if I'm her I would be like okay
so talk me through that let's run some
numbers let's look let's have a
conversation right not just you telling
him well this is what it is this what
you should be doing creaty
mentality um yeah being willing to
listen very much so questions and ask
questions be curious like that whole
Spirit as a person I think is really
important but when you're so closed off
and you don't even want a conversation
that to me is the big that's exhausting
like you know that would be a red flag
for me they won't even they won't even
talk about it they avoid it you know all
the stuff and you're just like oh man
yeah I think that's a red flag I think
if you're talking about the future like
say you're dating and you're talking
about okay like when we get married you
know what are your views on combining
money that like maybe maybe they've been
very open about their money up until
this point and you're like yes
everything's going good but then when
you start thinking about okay when we
get married how is this going to work
cuz I my thoughts are that we would
combine our money and kind of have our
goals together and if they're saying oh
really because I've worked really hard
for my savings and Y that for me would
be tough would be tough I think and and
a nonnegotiable I think it's a
non-negotiable but there's part I'm not
going to lie there's part of me that
wonders if there could be a journey
there mhm over time y so these are you
know these are tough conversations but I
I would urge people to start having them
early if there's one thing that I can
say that I kind of feel like I learned
in my marriage is we didn't talk about
that dating like yes our dating time was
very fun and not a lot of like we I mean
we talked about heavy stuff but somehow
the financial stuff just wasn't really
in there and then after the fact it was
like oh wait a minute luckily there were
certain things that we just naturally
aligned on thank goodness but yeah have
those
conversations and I would say debt would
be one of those I mean it would be
really tough to marry somebody and
they're like hey I want to go you know
$500,000 in debt to do real estate and
I'll be like oh no I can't do that I
can't do that I can't do that like that
would stress that would be cuz then you
live as the spouse in the stressful
State 24/7 you know in investment I'm
saying not just primary home but it's
like I because I see these people on
Instagram Tik Tok and they're all all
about real estate investment to their
eyeballs yes and I just watched that I'm
like oh my gosh that would be so hard
that would be a tough that would be a
tough marriage for me is because on the
one hand and I mean even if it's not
real estate even if it's just one person
like I have this business goal or this
aspiration I want to open a restaurant
whatever it is but their Viewpoint is I
go into debt to do this and if you're
the spouse who says hey I I don't feel
comfortable with debt I don't like that
and they view that as you're not
supporting my dream or you're not you
know what I'm saying like you don't
believe you don't believe this is going
to work and we'll be able to pay it off
that right there that's a very tough
conversation to have now don't get me
wrong I still Stand My Ground because I
feel like I'm not like can we do it over
time is there a way to not leverage debt
but yes yes oh goodness all good things
talk about it's hard
Andy good stuff all right let's go to
the phone lines where we've got Anna in
Houston Texas what's going on Anna Anna
hello how are you guys doing doing good
how are you sorry I said your name wrong
it's Anna right
you're okay it is
Anna um so I have a question and I'm
hoping that y'all can kind of help me
out I've been thinking about it for a
little while um I am expecting to get a
raise here soon within the next maybe
two months um at work and it's about I'm
hoping like 20,000 extra a
year um I'm not certain though if I
should save that amount every year or
use it to pay off my student loan debt
that's awesome I have about 60 yeah I
have about
$65,000 of student loan debt that I just
um accured here recently um going back
to school to get my
masters um and it's just me and my kids
I don't get child support how many kids
and I have three okay one my son is um
19 though now and so he's um wants to go
to school that's a whole another
situation and needing a little bit of
money for that yeah but I guess my
question is just should I save that
extra 20 a year for me and my kids just
like for security type stuff or should I
um just use it all to pay off this
student loan debt because I don't want
it to go from 65 to $200,000 of course
and that's a great way of thinking
number one congratulations on the raise
that's excellent um so if you're kind of
new to the Ramsay show we we teach
everything kind of through a series of
baby steps right there's these seven
baby steps that you can take that build
on each other um to ultimately get you
to this place of financial peace right
and so the advice that I'm going to give
you is based on that so the first thing
that we want to kind of create this
secure platform for you is you just need
$1,000 saved right so if you can just
out of that $20,000 raise or out of your
bank account or whatever you have of
money now if you can just set $1,000
aside and just okay I've got that there
and then the second baby step is yeah
you pay off your debt because when you
pay off debt you're eliminating that
risk you're eliminating that Financial
uncertainty that's in your life and that
that's usually the point of stress that
people feel is oh my gosh I've got to
make these payments or these debt
collectors are calling me or my payment
is due right that's usually the source
of stress that people um feel when it
relates to their money so in your case I
would say if you've got this extra money
congratulations let's put it to whatever
baby step you're on so that you can keep
going in the right direction to get to
that ultimate financial piece and it
sounds like in your case you would be on
baby step two where you are paying off
the debt Anna how much do you make in
your job
now um so I make about 4,000 a month
it's about 60,000 a year okay um
and then with the $20,000 will come so
that'll be about
80 and I already I have this I have the
emergency fund and I even have about
30,000 in a CD account that I put up
whenever I sold my house last year so I
have that
saved that's
great I I would put Onna I it's G to
make you nervous but I would put that
towards your debt and that will take a
huge chunk out of this debt and you're
going to make great m i mean you're
going to make 80 grand mhm so you'll
have $335,000 left I mean you could pay
this off in 18 24 months yeah and
honestly when that CD matures I'd
probably put that on the debt too and
knock it out
65,000 i' I would do that and then once
the debt is gone I'd save back up that
money and I just keep it in a high yield
to where it's like very liquid um but
yeah listen I'm proud of you I think
that you're doing all the right things
you've got good instincts and good
intuitions yes you're doing great taking
great care family this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial peace and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
you're listening to the ramsy show give
us a call the number is 88255 225 and we
would love to hear from you it's a new
year you probably have goals uh you
probably have questions and Rachel we
are here to answer answer those we have
a live stream coming up guys uh January
11th that's a Thursday night okay it's
at 7:00 p.m. it's completely free yes
all right it's going to be myself uh
Rachel Cruz John deloney George camel
and the Goat Dave Ramsey we're all going
to be there um and we're going to be
teaching you how to break the money
cycle all right we're breaking this
toxic cycle it's actually called Break
the cycle live stream but and it's our
biggest one yet Jade yes the the
registration is crazy yes over 200,000
people have registered so yeah come join
us we just had a meeting about it
yesterday and uh it's going to be really
great you guys we're going to talk a lot
about navigating money anxiety bad money
habits that keep you stuck some
practical tips practical on what to do
uh to start this New Year off so I hope
you join us not to mention if you
register you get entered to win $1,000
and we're doing 10 separate winners so
there's a good chance that you could win
$1,000 and that's some nice money that's
just a sign up you know all day some
free money all day I know that's right
all right let's go straight to the phone
lines with Joey in Washington DC what's
going on
Joey hey how are you all doing doing
good so I'm uh looking for some advice
so I'm looking to kind of invest and
save money as um an 18-year-old going
into trying to pay cash for college um
as well as trying to get um more like
guess better paying jobs into just kind
of like where I should start and where I
should look as far as investing
goes so do you have money Joey for
college uh yes so I actually um this is
like I'm starting my first semester in
college and so I've paid cash for this
semester upcoming okay um as well as
having a part-time job okay it's just
kind of what I need to do to continue
because I really don't want to go into
debt yeah and so it's kind of what I
need to do to stay out of debt and be
able to I kind of set myself up yeah
well it's a great question well in your
stage Joey I probably would not advise
investing right now uh if I were you I
would just open up a high yield savings
account and I would put as much cash in
there as possible and get through
college making sure that you can cash
flow it because what I don't want to
happen is you go and open up you know a
Vanguard account put some money in and
the market goes down and you need cash
for school and it's not there and you're
like oh geez you know I lost some of
that money and so you want to be able to
when you invest it's a really long-term
play so for something big a big expense
like college I would want you to go
through it completely and just know hey
I have money I'm able to cash flow this
and then when you graduate and you get a
job I would build up a a emergency fund
of 36 months of expenses and then I
would look to invest and when you're
investing you want to do 15% of your
income into retirement and so that's you
know 4 your 401k at work uh for the job
you'll get when you graduate to your
Roth IRA open that up so um so yeah I
would I would honestly not advise you to
invest right now just because college is
such a big expense and I want to make
sure you get through it debt
free okay so I should not be like even
into retirement or anything like that I
shouldn't be worrying about that till
like kind of after I get out of college
and I graduate college yeah and what's
hard Jo like you you know and we even
show a graph here at Ramsey that says if
you're 18 and you start investing what
it can be because compound interest is
it's an amazing thing but I don't again
want your money stuck in an investment
if you really do need it for college so
this idea that if you just wait four
years it's not going to be the end of
the world at all like you will be you
will be fine starting to invest in
retirement at 22 years old you will be
plenty fine you will you will retire a
millionaire everything will be fine uh
but I would again make sure that you get
through college Deb free but I
appreciate the the call and just the
thought process Joey of that because
investing is so important for our future
but also not going into debt is as
important so so 100% awesome thank you
for the call Joey well let's keep it
going and let's go to cat in Los Angeles
what's going on
cat hi there hey how are you I'm good
how are you doing good how can we help
today um my question is about tithing um
my husband and I have been married for
26 years and we've tithed 10% since day
one like that's never been a problem for
us okay I think the problem part if
anything has been like the 10% saving
like we've never done that but we own
our own business and we're the only two
employees and um for the past few years
we decided we should tithe the 10% off
of our gross income from our business
and we've definitely done that of the
expense of putting money into savings um
which I I'm so I love giving I think
it's important but the last few years
after Co we lost some clients um we you
know we're making way less than our
usual income and so basically now we're
looking at our budget for 2024 and we
really want to live the way that God
wants us to live and I mean we've always
tied like I said but but we're wondering
like would it be wrong to tie the 10% on
our personal income rather than our
business income listen and I really
really don't want to do the wrong thing
right I sort of feel like talking about
it we're just saying we're like hold up
hold up you feel too much guilt breathe
cat you're good you are good you're fine
okay you're fine first off you're giving
you're giving like which is puts you in
a very small Cate and you're giving 10%
which is good I mean I mean obviously if
you're a Christian person listening
you're used to that kind of talk it's
like okay yeah I give my tithe if you're
not a Christian person listening that's
what a lot of Christian people practice
is they give 10% to their local church
and um when you were telling your story
I was like oh that sounds like me and
Sam you know we when we first started
our business we were the only employees
and I will be honest like for us uh at
the stage in our life we wanted to give
that extra and we gave 10% of the gross
of our business and I mean you can't
outg give God and so we saw the fruit
from that but as we continued on and
things changed we we like okay like we
we now give uh 10% of our gross payroll
like what we take of the business like
what we take home just like anybody else
would right like if you work for
Walgreens you get your check and you
tithe off of what you receive and the
gross amount of what you receive
typically and I don't even want to get
like too funky fresh on the grosser the
net it's like I think the point of all
of this and I think the heart behind why
God has instructed that why he
encourages giving is because what it
does to us like what like giving what
that does is it opens our hands it it
moves us on the Spectrum from being
selfish just thinking about ourselves to
selfless looking up for others and
others needs uh when we give and what we
give to is really important because it's
it's transforming you know a community
or a place or an organization like like
that's the that's the heart behind it
that's the motivation it's not this tip
fortat gross or net business or like
that's not that's not why God wants us
to give it's not that legalistic it's
not that granular it it is the position
and the posture of our hearts and that's
what he's looking for because he knows
when we give that selflessness starts to
occur and you have a richer life I'm not
talking about money I'm talking about
you have a richer relationship with your
SP because as you're giving you're
becoming selfless and you become more of
that in your marriage as a parent as a
friend as an employee I mean like it
affects you as an entire human being
when giving is a part of a habit of your
life so agree that's what that that's my
philosophy of why God has called us to
that um and and it's a beautiful thing
and it's something that regardless if
you are you know a a person that is
spiritual or in the Evangelical you know
Christian space or not giving regard
regardless of where you land spiritually
we always encourage cuz that will do
that whether you believe in a God or not
um so for cat I really I appreciate your
diligence and you know wanting to do the
right thing like you said but I think
you are doing the right thing I think
it's the posture of your heart so I
would not get B out of shape and I do
think cat you will feel something from
the holy spirit that may say TI tie on
your business and Cat and be obedient to
that but he also may say you're okay and
and what we teach is tithing on on the
income you bring in like what Jade is
saying so that's where we always advise
people give on your
income but he may he call you know he
might encourage you to do something else
yeah you know $100 to the Sonic guy cuz
I just feel like we we do yeah so like
you can't mess this up cat yeah that's
right that's right you can't mess it up
if you feel the only way you can mess it
up is if you start doing things out of
obligation or you feel contention or you
feel like God loves a cheerful Giver
there's something in it of that Joy so I
don't yeah we don't want rob you of that
o I like that conversation I appreciate
you though I really do question that's a
good one I think a lot of people feel
that and you can get very like you said
granular is a great way you're like
looking oh my gosh I was 10 cents short
you know like what's this going to mean
when I get to the Pearly Gates nothing I
mean come on now guys this has been such
a great hour thanks for your calls we'll
be here next hour give us a call this is
the ramsy
show
[Music]
la
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm your host Jade warshaw
joined by your other host Rachel Cruz
we'll be taking your calls all hour so
give us a call the number Isle
8825 5225 we'll talk about whatever it
is that's on your mind especially in
this new year
um I'm sure you've got so much that
you're trying to accomplish this is the
season of setting goals right and I'm
sure so many of you have money goals
financial goals you're trying to save
money you're trying to get out of debt
you're trying to start the new habit of
budgeting and if that's you we've got
the perfect encouragement for you
because this is we're about to get into
the time Rachel that people already
start moonwalking right you y'all are
already Moon walking and I'm like wait a
minute it's only the fifth so you need
some encouragement and we've got that
for you Jan January 11th write this down
like George Strait said January 11th
this is Thursday all right 7 p.m. we are
doing a free uh live stream event and
it's actually live it's not pre-recorded
like some of these folks are doing it's
actually live and we're going to be
giving you the tools you need to break
the cycle and y'all know what I'm
talking about there's been a debt cycle
there's been a paycheck to paycheck
cycle and you're ready to get free and
you're like Jade Rachel how do we do
this help we're here to help it's free
guys you can register uh ramsy
solutions.com breakthe cycle and when
you register uh you can enter to win
$1,000 giveaway we're giving that
giveaway away to 10 different winners so
be sure to do that that's the break the
cycle live stream January 11th at 7 p.m.
be there or B Square as they say let's
go to Atlanta where we have Paige on the
phone line what's going on at uh
Paige hi um first of all I just want to
say thank you for taking my call I feel
very blessed to get to speak speak to
you both today um my question is so I
have the every dollar app and the baby
steps app on my phone and so I'm on step
number two the Deb snowball and my
situation is kind of unique um and that
my I'm only 26 years old and my mom is
disabled and my dependent now um she got
really sick a couple years ago and we
finally kind of got out out of the
craziness of the last couple years into
like a Zone where I feel very fortunate
to be now where her health is better she
lives with me and not in a facility
which that was a lot of money um and you
know she's not doing Hospital trips and
things like that anymore fortunately
hopefully fingers crossed um but with
that you know she has debt I have debt
so my plan I'm trying to tackle kind of
both of our debts and I manage both of
our finances I mean we live together we
basically share finances um and manage
medical everything basically okay um so
you know I put all the debts into the
baby steps app where and put like the
money that we can put on a monthly basis
towards the debt and we can pay a little
currently because she's got some
insurance P um policies as well as her
retirement right now for the next 2 and
1 half years um we can put like 2,600 to
$3,000 a month towards our debt which
kind of totals like
$90,000 um and that's a combination of
her credit card debt her medical debt my
credit card debt my student loans and my
car um so how does it break down between
the two of you I'm just curious I know
yeah number one you're a hero like it's
admirable that you're doing this and
you've honestly essentially put your
life on hold to help your mom and you're
seem more than willing to combine your
debts like that's not normal and like
good on you for choosing that um but I
am curious because you are two separate
people um and so I just I do want to
know out of the 90,000 of debt what's
what's yours and what's
hers so um I have 25,000 with Sally May
um for price loan for student loan um
7700 in Federal loans my car is
26,000 um I just got that one new this
last summer that's a whole other
story and I have like seven or 8,000 in
credit cards um and then as far as I
know um my mom has
$30,000 in credit cards
18 on one card about seven another about
you know 7,700 on another we fortunately
have had one card like I don't know what
the proper word is but like pardon us or
whatever and just all charged it off
yeah and we wrote it on the taxes and
all that stuff so we had one C do that
cuz my dad had you know her ex-husband
he's an attorney and um he had been
helping me try to alleviate some of her
like hardship type yeah you know as far
as yeah cuz I mean basically when she
got sick I was on the under the
oppression that she managed her money
well and she had a lot of money and
savings that's at least what the
situation was when my parents got
divorced when I was eight uhuh something
happened and she had a higher loan on
the
house 12 years after purchasing the
house higher than what she bought it for
but now she's now the only
30,000 in credit cards and is mostly the
credit card medical or is that separate
no that's that's all the credit card
that she had once I got into her account
and then what's the medical debt She
carries so that I have like a I have
,000 dollar that I know of we
fortunately been able to get the
hospital wanted to do 16,000 we did the
like final thing and they wrote that off
I think ambulances for for time let me
let me get into this um the car that's
the first thing I'm looking at because
what's your take-home
pay um or what do you make per year
4,000 a year okay um if you really want
to move through this I would consider
getting out of this car and getting into
something cheaper you just got it you
should be able to sell it kind of break
even and take some cash and buy
something cheaper five or $6,000 I would
do that um because I think it's worth it
for you to move quickly on this I'm a
little bit inclined for you to have two
separate snowballs here and for your mom
to have her money and you put your mom's
money at her debt and you put your money
on your debt and you're the you're just
the one stewarding all of it and making
it all happen but I don't want you
combining them and combining the money
because you are two separate people with
two your names on two separate sets of
bills and at the end of the day even
though you've combined your lives in
many ways you're still two separate
people and you're not married and P and
and the truth is too you know this is
not to be harsh on you but you know
you've you've gotone $8,000 in credit
cards out you've taken on a Carl and
your behavior and habits are one way and
when you feel the weight of oh gosh it's
not going to be an insurance policy
that's going to be paying off my debt I
have to do this that changes your
behavior page and that's what we're all
about here is your behavior has to
change and by you doing the work and
paying off that debt that's going to
cause the behavior change so I want you
guys to be cutting up these credit cards
I want you to be selling the car you
guys really have to clean this up you
are in a you're in a dire situation of
like there's a lot of mess here but you
can get it cleaned up you really really
can but you have to change the way
you've been viewing it and so Paige
you're doing an amazing job taking care
of your mom absolutely incredible but
your money habits and where this is Led
has gotten you guys in that spot so that
has to change that has to change today
cut up the cards this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
mended blinds.com for over a decade so
you know you can trust them from blinds
drapes and shutters to motorized Shades
they make it easy and affordable to
upgrade your entire home and their team
is ready to help with everything from
design consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
you're listening to the ramsy show I am
Jade warshaw your host joined by Rachel
Cruz and we are taking your calls all
hour long the number Isle
8825 5225 give us a call and we'll chop
it up with you um you know we're always
looking at at what the what's going on
in finance what's going on on social
media what's going on in the news and
what the trends are because this is what
people are talking about and we want to
be talking about what y'all are talking
about and what's important to you guys
and so um I saw initially an article
come across my email that was talking
about this and then there's Tik toks and
it kind of started popping off a little
bit so I was like we need to talk about
this and it's essentially um Rachel this
idea that if you make $74,000 a year um
Jen Z doesn't think that that's middle
class like they don't think they don't
agree with that and so I don't want to
say much more I want you guys to watch
this and decide for yourself and then we
will
discuss gen ZZ doesn't agree that
$74,000 is middle class no kidding it's
not even close check this out if you
take $74,000 for a genen z or let's say
they have a bachelor's degree and
they're 25 years old first of all 74,000
is much higher than the average income
most gen zers are probably making
anywhere from 40 to 50 maybe 60 but
let's use 74 the take-home after taxes
401K in health insurance is $ 4300 the
average college monthly payment on a
loan is about 500 bucks you're down to$
3,800 let's say this person is
financially responsible decides to split
a two-bedroom apartment in a
medium-sized City like Orlando so that
their payment is 1,200 a piece 200 for
utility so400 now unless they're going
to have Lucky Charms and peut butter and
jelly their groceries are going to cost
about 600 bucks if they're trying to get
chicken beef and some healthy stuff you
have a $400 car payment $200 Insurance
$150 for gas $100 for a cell phone
leaves you with 950 bucks this is no
savings investment no emergency fund
let's give them at least 300 to go on a
couple dates or hang out with their
friends for the month so they can enjoy
life a little bit they're left with only
$650 a bachelor's degree 74k salary you
are splitting a two-bedroom apartment
with a friend and only have $650 left a
month it would take you years to save up
the $30,000 that you would need for a
down payment on a house with the closing
cost but even if you could get that down
payment saved you would still need to
make
$120,000 a year to be considered for a
$400,000 loan the middle class the
goalpost has been moved from 70k to
$120,000 in just the past 2
years okay okay uh I got some thoughts
Rachel Cruz I did too you go Jade um
number one when my guy said only $650
left there are a couple of things that
are screaming at me a only $650 left I
think that if you're just starting out
you're in your
20s I'm like yeah that's that if you're
22 years old and you have $650,000 left
over come on somebody number two pretty
good that's good then I'm like okay I'm
just getting into $300 on fun money
again that's a lot of money like that
ain't bad I'm can I be 100% real talk
yeah on my budget right now where it
says Jade fund money it's
$300 and I'm telling you I more than
$74,000 a year so okay okay and then so
then add in which is normal I get but
what if you decided to get an extra job
and pay off this debt you would free up
a car payment $ and free up $500 student
loan so that's $900 $600 for groceries
for a single person I think you can do
it at 500 so that's an extra hundred
that you pick out so so there's an extra
thousand so that's really
$1600 extra uh yeah I think I think
we're okay I think this is an
expectation conversation yes yes and
we're not going to make $774,000 forever
ever amen no or $40,000 forever and ever
and amen or whatever it is right as you
get older and you work you will be
making more money over your lifetime
that is true I I just I this really
rubbed me the wrong way Rachel I just I
think that like what you said this is
all expectation and it's kind of tunnel
vision and getting in the now you know
it's like you're looking at everything
that you're seeing on social media and
you're creating this bar of what you
should have you're even looking at maybe
what friends and family members have
like so many people they come out of
their parents' house and you've been
living in this environment where there's
um nicer cars the the home is larger um
and you immediately kind of feel like oh
yeah I'm supposed to have that too and
I'm like listen these things take time
it took time for our parents to get
where they are if that's what you're
comparing it to yeah and and we'll say
this I'll say this number one has life
changed yeah over time yes absolutely is
stuff more expensive real estate being
one yeah yes like like we are not
denying that of course it is it is more
expensive but the problem I have with it
is is honest it's kind of it's kind of
his attitude of like oh my God versus
saying well I have $650 what can I do
now to better my life with that what do
we you know what mean there's a there's
an attitude shift as well of how you
view this you can view it like eore or
you can view it like this is an
opportunity so what am I going to do
what am I going to do different how am I
going to pay off debt so I can free up
an extra thousand a month yes how what
am I what are what's my opportunity here
to do what if I invested 300 of the
$350 every month from 22 to you know run
those numbers like like find the
opportunity in it I agree versus this
like well you're you're all screwed
we're all just screwed I don't know what
we're going to do you know and you're
just like oh my gosh like yeah they're
approaching it from the wrong angle it's
just like yeah that drives me crazy I
agree it's like oh must be nice like you
you're looking at it and like you said
he's $50 that's a lot of money oh that's
where I'm like listen I'm standing on
business that's $650 a lot real talk
what we what we do on the show is talk
to real people every single day for
three hours a day people are in the red
they don't have $650 left over so and
that's what I'm saying the mind said if
you if it's almost like he's solving the
wrong problem or focusing on the wrong
thing and not just him cuz there's he
he's speaking for yeah totally hundreds
and you know thousands maybe millions of
people who feel this way but if you're
like you said If you're looking at $650
that's not enough and you're looking at
um $400 and he's not addressing that and
he's not addressing the the student loan
it's just this is the way it is there's
nothing that's going to change you're
looking at the wrong piece of the puzzle
you've got to look at I was listening to
somebody today that was saying that
healthy people um whether it's in a
relationship or just you as yourself you
always look at something and go okay
what am I contributing to this like if
there's a problem it's very easy to
point out there and say it's because of
that that that that and that but when
you're um healthy and have this area of
maturity you're always looking at and
going what can I own in this situation Y
and if you're finding yourself even if
it's not a $74,000 budget that we're
looking at if you're looking at your own
finances and you just find yourself
feeling trapped blaming your job blaming
the fact that you have student loans
blaming your spouse you have to stop for
a moment and go okay wait a minute what
am I contributing to the situation cuz
here's the guarantee if there is
something that you're complaining about
in life I don't care what it is at this
point I'm beyond money if there's
something that you're complaining about
I guarantee I bet your bottom dollar
there's there's something that you are
doing that's contributing even if it's
slightly that you can tweak to make your
situation better and if you start to
turn the dial up on that and start
focusing on that that's going to point
to another thing that you can change and
you start focusing on that and that
points to another thing so it really
goes back to that idea of whatever
you're looking for that's what you find
so if you're looking for problems all
you find is problems if you look for
Solutions you're going to start to see
even if it's so small like Rachel you
just went through all of this like okay
like what would happen if you paid off
your car what would happen if you paid
off your student loan what would happen
start asking yourself those questions
what can you contribute listen equation
at that point I know and I do wonder you
mentioned it earlier but expectations
and this is something I always wrestle
with and it's and it it almost could be
just subconscious of what we just
naturally expect in our world cuz we're
so exposed to everyone's lifestyle I
mean whether it's like reality TV or
social media Instagram Tik Tok like you
see into people's lives more than any
other time in history yeah and you start
to see a glimpse and you start to expect
what you see you become numb to it
almost and it's like oh this is normal
and if I don't have that I'm not normal
I was talking to my mother-in-law
Christmas and she was like oh my God you
know she just made a comment how all
they did with their little kids at the
time they just all played in the
driveway and all the coldest SEC will
get together and now I'm like there's
memberships to things like there's all
this stuff that's normal but I'm like
that wasn't that's not that that doesn't
have to be nor yeah so it's just this
like subconscious expectation we have to
reevaluate all the time and I think it's
really important to keep us grounded in
it because you can just float off into
this world spend a lot of money that's
unnecessary and complain and doing Tik
Tok video that's a word Rachel that's a
word right there check out your
expectations figure out what's
motivating you is it the money or is it
an emotion that you're seeking out this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show well you've all played the
telephone game the first person Whispers
a message to the second person who
Whispers it to the third and so on
around the table until the original
message has completely changed multiply
that confusion by a 100 if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's Nets Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netw week gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more
get a free product tour at nets.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I am
your host Jade warshaw joined by your
other host Rachel Cruz and we are with
you today so give us a call the number
Isle
88255 225 we will call we will take your
call and answer your questions uh
today's question of the day is sponsored
by neighborly your hub for Home Services
now you can find expert local help you
can schedule appointments and get
special offers exclusively in the
neighborly app so download the
neighborly app now and get started on
your home repairs maintenance and Home
Improvements done today's question comes
from Ryan in Arizona my wife and I have
been using the envelope system for over
15 years and debt-free for almost that
long awesome my wife takes care of the
finances but we make decisions together
and trust each other the issue I have is
at the beginning of each month the
envelopes still get the same amount of
money they did when we started 15 years
ago he should talk to the Tik Tok guy
that we
were I can't convince my wife to
increase it is it part of your budgeting
system to increase the amount in the
envelopes as the cost of things goes up
please help oh Ryan yes tell your wife
to put some more money in those
envelopes if youall have it which I'm
assuming you do it's been 15 years yes
so I mean what we say is once you're out
of debt you have the ability now with
your income to do more with the three
things you can always do with money be
giving more be saving more and you can
be spending more so increasing your
lifestyle I would do it by percent
points so you guys yeah I mean up
everything by 10% 15% for a little bit
right and and just feel that um now I
also will say uh we were just talking
about our personal line items in the
break because uh the Tik Tok video we
just talked about in the last segment
and and I've not in I have not increased
some of ours dramatically we've
increased our out to eat yeah our
groceries sum um with everything kind of
going on and adding more kids but ours
is not
dramatically it's not dramatically
different it really isn't like I look at
I spend more on clo like maybe by again
by small percentages um and so I think
that's what you that's what you want to
work in yeah I I'm I'm thinking about
what you're saying and I'm thinking
about this question and you know I'm
with you I reluctantly raised our
grocery budget you know when inflation
got crazy I tried to stick to the old
numbers and finally I remember coming
home and being like listen it doesn't
work like I gotta raise this item um and
so I do remember doing that um I think
if it's when it's gradual like I think
what she's trying to avoid here is
lifestyle creep yeah or well let me go
back your girl needs to loosen the the
purse strings I think she's just super
tight but I think most people what their
hesitation is is they're trying to avoid
lifestyle cre yes and that's a good
conversation to have because when you
start earning more and you're like okay
I'm doing better I'm out of debt like
I've done all the things sometimes there
is still that guilt that you face of can
I really spend this like can I really do
this for my myself um and I'm going to
go with as long as you're taking care of
business the answer is yes sure I mean
yes absolutely and you want to be be
able to enjoy your life and I think
that's part of it too so increasing it
but increasing the other areas too be
increasing your giving and your saving
but doing all three with extra money is
is really important so yep Brian
probably more after 15 years up up it a
little bit and I want to I want to hit
one more thing on that because with
spouses um be willing to like your
spouse can be into something that you're
not into and they want to spend some
money on something that you would never
spend money on sure and it's like I feel
like that's when it gets a little
difficult it's like hey we're making
this money now I love I'm really into
this and you know my husband would be
like why would you ever like do you know
what I'm saying like I remember being on
here with Dave and we were talking about
wine or something and he was like a $300
bottle of wine I'm like I would never
like I spent I spent $9.99 on wine Dave
like I I could he was like oh go get
yourself a bottled I was like I can't I
like I physically can't do it like
there's certain stuff that I just yes I
can't I can't do it Captain don't make
me please don't make me do oh gosh I got
to go to the phone lines this is Kennedy
in Pittsburgh PA what's going on
Kennedy hi ladies thanks so much for
taking my call I have a couple things um
my husband and I have been married
almost 34 years and you know we've
worked hard our entire lives to build
what we have built and we're B A
Crossroads on on a few things and um we
have 17 rental properties that we have
acquired um they're all paid for wow
great job Kennedy this is this is the
question I have you know you would think
because you know we want to retire
eventually we've never taken vacations
we've never been extravagant with things
um we have no debt
whatsoever um this is what we're at AC
crossfits because we were envisioning
that's when we retire you know all our
rental income which is over 200 a year
would just keep us afloat and not have
to dip into what we've built over the
years um now I'm noticing that the
rental income is just not growing like
it should and so we're trying to decide
if we should sell the properties which
are probably worth around 3.2 to 3.5
million in total and just put the money
you know in in away and earn the
interest off of it because you know just
in property taxes alone like I just
wrote a check for almost
$50,000 just recently for property taxes
on some of the property and so I'm just
trying to make you know and if one if an
air condition goes out or you know I
mean it things just add up and it's like
that account doesn't build like I think
it should build why haven't the rental
why haven't why hasn't the rent gone
up well I do go up on the rant now I
will say I'm I I am terrible because I
managed them all and I am I'm a very
sweet
landlord I don't go up like I should
especially if they've been there there's
a lot of longevity with my tenants you
know so I know there's room for growth
on that um but it just I just feel like
you know the expenses you know if we
just with draw an interest we could
probably draw the same amount in
interest um every year than what we
would be actually bringing in I don't
think you should feel guilty about you
know you're in a real estate business
essentially and I don't think you should
feel guilty about passing along the cost
of business to the customer and for you
as a landlord there are prices that
increase and some of that you do pass
along and I don't think you should feel
guilt in that now if you're still
interested in selling I you know I have
my thoughts on this Rachel you know far
more about real estate than I do so you
take R not really um yeah that's where
and I don't want to sound cold-hearted
um but where you've chosen to put your
money and your Investments is in real
estate and real estate involves people
so when you have a big heart like you
Kennedy and you see it like that you're
not going to get the same return
financially when you don't raise rents
right I mean that that's just the that's
the mathematical fact so my question to
you would be if it's less hassle less
work and you're going to get a bigger
return somewhere else then yeah would
probably highly consider that or if you
say no real estate is my endgame uh it's
it is my business in a sense it's my
investing my investment because I want a
percentage of what I you know I've
bought this this is the rental I mean
the rent basically is is your income
it's what you're making and your income
has to stay at market value and if
that's how you run it then I think we're
having a different conversation but it
doesn't sound like you necessarily want
to run it like that um well you know the
the rental properties are just a side
husb you know my I have my own business
and my husband's also an executive cor
company so we both still work how much
do youall make a year off those off that
um without okay we're at 800 a year okay
without the rental
income and so the rental income was just
okay is it a hassle for you Kennedy like
are you to the point in Life or you're
like I don't want to deal with 18
tenants and I would rather it is a
hassle that's it I think I think real
estate has to be a passion and for some
people they love the diversity they love
getting a property getting a good price
at the at the front end and they're
doing I mean it is part in their blood
that would be Dave if he was sitting
here he he loves it but if but if it's a
hassle for you yeah and if it's a hassle
for you and you don't love it you don't
need to be in it in my opinion there may
be a level though Kennedy that you keep
maybe five of these or something just
for the divers diversification aspect so
I think having real estate as part of
your over all especially where you guys
are financially would be smart so maybe
you you sell half of them cut the
expenses in half pick your half that you
love keep those for a few more years and
then if you look up Kennedy and you're
still miserable managing these sell them
yeah I mean like this is this is the joy
of your like you want joy in your life
and if it's sucking the joy out of your
life don't do it the great thing is
they've got choices like that's what I
love in conversations like this is she
has choices she's not like chained to
one option so when you are paying look
at the taxes like you need to look at
the entire picture too uh if you decide
to sell these that's a very very good
point this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
you are listening to the ramsy show I'm
Jade warshaw joined by Rachel Cruz hey
if you like this show uh consider liking
and subscribing uh wherever it is that
you listen whether it's on YouTube or
your favorite podcast app when you like
And subscribe and share it helps in so
many ways number one it helps other
people find this and use this message
and find these resources and hopefully
change their life and obviously it helps
us on our end because it helps us in the
algorithms there a couple of weeks ago
Rachel we were number one yes um in
podcasting on Spotify which that list is
always changing and in my heart we're
still number one but and an apple I
looked it up on this podcast yeah yes
I'd love it and that's really all
because of you guys so keep liking keep
subscribing and keep sharing in the New
Year we're so so grateful all right
let's take it to the phone lines we got
Victoria in Austin Texas what's going on
Victoria hey you guys how are you great
how are you I'm doing great um so my
question was uh what Financial steps
should I take as a college student with
around I would say $155,000 in savings
um considering I have no assets a small
school loan of about 1300 and a credit
score of 693 and then this is like a
two-part question I also wanted to know
like any college or not College advice
any um advice you guys have for young
adults um especially FR gen College
grads on managing finances and you know
setting myself up for success and
Building Wealth and what not to do as
well man you're so smart like I'm so
proud of you first generation college
grad asking all the right questions
awesome it's so so so good um yeah I
mean I I'll I I'll throw my two cents in
and I'm sure Rachel has plenty to say um
I think you're thinking the right way
number one you're out of school you're
graduated do you plan on going back to
school or is this it like are you going
into your career now I have one more
semester left and I graduate in May okay
and then I plan to go straight into my
career um but hopefully down the line I
want to go to grad school for like MBA
okay so cool um yeah my first thing is
like let's let's get through this final
semester let's graduate with a degree um
let's get you into a stable job like in
in your field and then yeah I'd probably
start looking at this and going okay
first things first I want to get out of
debt you don't have a a whole ton I mean
13,000 in student loans so my first
things first I'd be like all right I'm
going to commit to walking the baby
steps and so I'm going to you know keep
$1,000 set aside and then the rest that
you have the 14,000 I'd pay off your
student loan immediately coming out of
school that'd be my first order of
business and that leaves you with
$22,000 and then I'd just start saving
up you know I'd be like all right once
you're you know stable does that make
sense cuz you're going to graduate
you're probably I don't know if you
already have a place are you living on
your own are you living on
campus um so after I graduate I plan to
be home for the first semester I mean
not the first semester for the rest of
the year um and then I want to work work
remote and then that job will probably
transfer me to a different location yeah
then year then that's perfect you're at
home for a year you're paying off this
debt immediately but then during that
year you're saving up a bunch of money
so that when you're ready to strike out
on your own the job sends you somewhere
you can get your own place or maybe it's
a place with roommates and so you've
really just set yourself up you've got
no debt you've got 3 to six months of
expenses and you've got money in order
to get a place for yourself and I don't
mean buy a place I mean like rent a
place but you know you you have that
margin in your life how does that sound
that sounds great thank you guys yeah
and and Victoria I think you know long
term I think one of the best things that
you can do from as a young person kind
of moving into this adulthood and money
is be proactive I think one of the worst
things that people can do with their
money is they become apathetic they're
almost reactive to life or they don't
really care that much I mean they're
just kind of floating they lose a lot of
time and they end up losing a lot of
money and so if you are just proactive
with your income and you budget every
month you know where your money's going
you avoid debt like the plague you just
say you just draw a hard light in the
sand that Victoria just is a person that
doesn't go into debt I don't go into
debt and you can avoid paying interest
and you can avoid being owned by by the
Banks and you are your income is
completely free you invest early um
invest in you know and save up for a
good down payment on a home later you
know maybe two three years down the road
uh and you do that wisely and you're
investing early and you do all of these
things overtime Victoria you're going to
be great you're going to do just fine
but I think your attitude towards money
it has to be proactive you have to own
the fact that you have to be the one in
control and you learn early Victoria and
I still feel like I learn it even in my
mid-30s it's kind of this like reality
like swoosh that happens for me where
I'm like oh it's up to me yeah like I no
one's no one's making my annual doctor
visit like I have to take care of myself
like and now I have kids and I have to
take care of them and no one advocating
for them I have to be the one to speak
you know so it's just it's this idea
that you really are in charge of your
life and that removes a lot of you know
victim mentality I think that removes a
lot of expecting someone else to take
care care of you and to fix stuff for
you when you just kind of Own It
Victoria from the front end that's going
to do a lot it really is it's going to
do a lot for your money so there's a lot
of tactical things um yeah and if you
stay on the line Victoria Austin will
pick up and I would love um to give you
one of my books know yourself know your
money which lays out the baby steps
within it but also understanding why you
handle money the way you do and you
already have Tendencies around money
Victoria you already have habits around
money that you may not even realize but
understanding your why why you handle
money the way you do when you can learn
that early on you can create great money
habits for the future kind of what we're
talking about on this call so I
appreciate you calling in because man
it's so big and all you Jers out there
there's a lot of them that have been
listening and finding us on Tik Tok all
the places but for real you guys I'm
like you know when you when you listen
to this show or you follow ramay and our
advice you know we kind of get we kind
of get uh in the corner of the old
School uh way of thinking but I'm
telling you day in and day out this is
the way to do it it really is so whether
you are Victoria and you're 21 years old
about to finish college or you're 61
wherever you are be proactive in this
stuff you guys and follow the baby steps
and do it because it works it works
mathematically it works in so many ways
I like I like what you're saying Rachel
and honestly it's reminding me um
earlier we were in a meeting together
and Dr John delone one of the Ramsey
personalities was mentioning how kind of
the way culture is and Society is
definitely wants us to go into kind of
um hands-off mentality and I just can
farm this out to them and they'll take
care of it and I can take my hands off
here and I can automate this and
automate that and there is part of that
where your mind kind of goes to sleep
on um having it front of Mind does that
make sense um and there is part of that
that going through life there's been
Seasons where I've been like you want to
know what like this might sound stupid
but there's been Seasons where like
you're giving you can automate it right
and it's like all right I can set it and
forget it and it's not part of my
day-to-day and it's like oh before you
look up it's like I've been giving the
same amount for two years right but then
there's those moments where it's like
you know what I'm going to take that off
Automation and I'm going to be
actively part of this each month to
where I know okay how does how am I
feeling what is my involvement in this
even like paying bills um there's
certain bills that I'm like you know I
don't want to like back in the day there
was like I don't want to automate that
like I want see I want to feel the money
going out I want to know and I want it
to register in my brain that I just made
a payment like there's something to that
being an active participant yes you're
actively participating and you're not
just putting it on the Shelf you're not
just letting someone else handle it y
does that make sense absolutely such a
good conversation Rachel I love it but
the proactiveness is is huge around this
yeah I like that listen I don't know do
you want to take try to take this next
call can we do it quickly all right
let's do it uh Jacob and San Francisco
what's going on in your
world hello um so I have a kind of a
situation going on where I just got a
$7,000 dental bill and um I have like
pretty substantial savings I'm pretty
young too I'm like 23 years old okay and
my situation is basically this so I have
two options either I could just pay it
all at once up front and just get rid of
it yep or I have a high interest savings
account with Sofi it's like 5% and I um
they offered me to take out like an
interest free loan over 28 months no off
no I got to cut you
off no just paid off reach into your
savings and paay it off okay I was
thinking like if I if I had that money
sitting over those two years it would
actually like ACW like some no it's it's
a $7,000 dental bill that you have the
cash to pay off don't don't complicate
it I know and we try to we try to
finagle numbers like that Jacob and try
to figure out what works in our favor
all of this but the truth is when you
don't have a debt hanging over your head
you make different decisions in life
there there's a freedom there and that
it's not hanging around and you're not
trying to play the math game so yes pay
it off be done with it and be grateful
my gosh that you have the money to do
that Jacob that's amazing you're
diligent and incredible so just yep set
it forget it and then go and invest and
make money that way ah love it love it
listen a dental bill is not going to be
the thing that breaks you free
financially on the interest I love it
this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
a
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am your host Jade
warshaw I am joined by author and host
of The Rachel Cruz show Rachel Cruz we
will be taking your calls all hour so
give us a call phone lines are open the
number is 8825
5225 we'll talk about your life your
money relationships and money kids and
money whatever it is that is on your
mind we would like to talk about that
with you and hopefully help you with
that so let's go straight to the phone
lines where we have hunter in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania what's going
on hey guys how you doing we're doing
good how can we help yes it's more of a
question of like what would you do in my
my shoes basically uh my wife is in
school for 18 more months um and and we
will be renting till she finishes just
based on proximity and commutability and
things like that at the end of that we
know we'll stay in the area for like
five to seven years we're thinking of
buying but we never wanted to time the
market to buy necessarily but we know it
will be a shortterm you know five to
seveny year home we just don't know if
maybe like buying with that shortterm in
mind is a smart thing since we know
we'll be moving um back to Virginia at
that point or if we should just continue
renting keep P money away for more
equity in the house down the road that's
interesting um where you guys at
financially Hunter do you guys have are
would you be in a spot in 18 months to
be able to buy a home have a good down
payment you letting the mortgage be no
more like have you guys run the numbers
like would you be able to do that
financially absolutely yeah so we
definitely have the down payment and you
know in 18 more months you'll just be
you know we could own a more expensive
house and not necessarily we're doing
that but financially we are stable in
that sense for sure yeah I mean I
probably would buy if it's going to be
if it's going to be 5 to seven years I
would I would and the fact of the matter
is like like if you want to make God
laugh tell them your plans like that's
the kind of way I feel like I think it's
good to have a plan but you never know
you might get in the area and decide to
stay like I just feel like there's a lot
of factors in a seven-year window and
for that reason I wouldn't rent the
entire time yeah yeah that makes sense
yep go ahead and buy but again under
making sure yeah you're debt free you
got to down payment emergency fund all
the things check all those boxes we uh
we give you the thumbs up to do it love
it cuz I really do think you know when
you look over the scope of time with
real estate it's going to go up right I
know there's been downtimes I know all
the things but over the scope of at
least 5 to seven years you're going to
see a return on that and so and then you
can use that as Equity when you go buy
home and he goes and leaves and buy goes
to Virginia so yeah I agree seven years
also it's just a long time to lose out
on yeah but yeah yeah like not that
renting is losing out but it's just if
you don't have to that's right if you
have the ability to buy and you have
that time if it was 18 months I'd say no
don't have don't mess with that yeah
absolutely uh but five years I would
very good question thanks for the
question Hunter let's go on to Newark
New Jersey where we're talking to Mike
what's going on
Mike hey Jorden Rachel thanks for taking
my call you're welcome how can we
help so my wife and I are going to
combine our finances as soon as this
weekend and we're just trying to figure
out how split our money between either a
high yield savings account or a generic
Bank savings account when our goal is to
save 20% for a down payment okay cool
I'm happy that you guys are starting to
combine your finances are you newly
married or is this just something you
decided to do because you think it's the
right thing to do so we're married about
a year and we're just finally fully
committing into it awesome um so you're
interested in buying a house you're
saving up for the 20% down payment where
is the best place to put this money
right
yes I mean I'd probably put I'd put it
in a high yield savings account that's
what I would do um yeah you're going to
make more interest on a high yield
savings um and usually some of the best
ones I found Mike Jade I don't know what
you've found but that usually it's like
an online bank yeah we like my husband
and I we have one we use Ally Bank for
oh there you go for for our high yield
savings so a traditional savings account
you're not going to make as much
interest um you may have more
flexibility to get money out when needed
with that high yield you have you you're
not able to use it like a standard
checking right there there's a limited
number of transactions but yeah and
you're not using it for that you're
using it to save up for a down payment
you're not going to touch the money once
it's in so those are the kind of the big
you know obvious differences in it so
yeah you're and right now Mike I'm like
the the high yield savings when the
interest went up with the FED with the
debt it also went up with the savings so
we we found some good some great rates
with high yield savings uh so yeah
that's that's the uh the I would take
for sure I love it does that answer your
question so you you wouldn't put
anything in a uh generic Bank savings
account just put it all how you put it I
put it all there but if you have Mike uh
you you know for like an emergency fund
and that kind of thing I would have
separate line items within that account
to know hey this is our emergency fund
we're not touching this this this is our
dump for our downum payment so even if
you wanted two different accounts or
within the same account we have line
items in that so yeah this is not a an
ad for Ally by any means um but I do use
Ally and they have buckets there so you
can you could either I mean you could
make another account if you wanted to
but honestly you can just put them in
different buckets and you can see it
that way honestly I think with that it
depends on your temperament and cuz some
people like there was a stage in my life
where I definitely mentally would have
done better with a separate account
fors versus that yep so whatever you
think will work better for you and your
wife
all right awesome yeah I saw Ally had
the buckets and that just seemed like
the easiest way to do it yeah I mean
some people like marus like there's
different banks like people have
different preferences so don't see this
as an ad like do your research figure
out the one that you like but definitely
I would Veer towards an online yield
savings account hope that answers your
question Rachel I think there's a lot
that you can talk about when it comes um
when it comes to savings um because a
lot of people struggle with saving money
whether it's for a down payment
emergency fun or just in general they've
never um built that muscle of savings
cuz it really is yeah a muscle that you
build over time and I always these are
we can go through a couple of tips that
I think will help people um I definitely
think that if you have savings you need
to put it in a separate location like we
just talked about versus a checking yes
it can't be grouped all in there
together and you just mentally know like
well this is my savings like that's
number one um your 3 to 6 months I think
that you know once you get that to a
place keep that separate from any other
savings whether it's through buckets or
depending on your mentality like we
talked about in a completely different
location um I think another great way to
save like if you're just if it's tough
for you that's one thing that I would
automate we talked earlier in other SE
segments about not automating savings is
something that I would set up like once
you kind of know what your budget is
it's like all right this automatically
comes out of my paycheck the day that I
get paid like don't mess around yeah
don't mess around and you know put it
for a couple days later because before
you know it that money's going to be
gone so that'd be my thing to and thing
three these are not in any particular
order by the way but you've got a budget
for savings yes you have to know that
you have the margin for it and and
prioritize against it right that's right
PR against it yeah if you have a you
know you want to hit a certain amount
for a down payment in two years you have
to back out and say okay how much we
have to save per month and that's going
to affect our budget that's our goal so
you kind of plan it out that way um but
but it is I like the the automation
factor in it I think is really good
because it creates the discipline um but
the budgeting aspect is so key because
if you don't budget and you do an
automated transfer for savings and then
something comes up before you know
you're pulling that savings right back
out and nothing Rachel is more
frustrating than that wheel of saving
and spending saving and spending so
budget for your savings that's so good
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
yeah
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
Jade warshaw your host joined by your
other host Rachel Cruz we're taking your
calls about life and money so give us a
call the number is 8825 5225 and we will
be here for you it's the New Year I'm
wondering what your goals are uh if
you're anything like the rest of the
population it's probably one or two
things money or health right it's like
you're on a cleanse you're on a diet and
you're trying to get this budget in
order if that's you I've got two things
for you to consider number one we have a
wonderful resource coming up here on
January 11th it is a break the cycle
free live stream all right so you can
register for free it's January 11th at
700 p.m. and we're going to give you
practical steps on how to get your money
on point and in check if you're one of
these people who you're like man no
matter what I feel like I just can't get
ahead I feel like I'm living paycheck to
paycheck this this really is for you um
all of us are teaming up and we are just
hitting you with a onew punch of money
knowledge to get you through the new
year and Beyond okay so I want you to
sign up and register for that next thing
is in order to get prepped for that
because you're going to get some
information you're going to learn about
every dollar you're going to learn so
much and then after that I want you to
mark your calendar because January 31st
I'm going to be doing a webinar
basically going over again what you
learned at the live stream so those are
two dates I want you to remember January
11th January 31st
go January 11th is free get the get the
get the knowledge right get the game and
then come again January 31st and I will
reup you on the knowledge and you'll
keep going forward and you need that
because
Rachel goals it's not easy like you have
to keep you have to keep at it like um I
posted on social media I think it was
today I posted when you set these goals
right um it's like you're all excited
it's January 1st she's like I writee it
down I'm like all excited about it and
then the resistance starts coming and
you're like oh I didn't know it was
going to be like that like and the thing
is the resistance doesn't like if you
set a money goal you're like all right
this year I'm paying off my debt
whenever I have extra money I'm throwing
it on my debt and then suddenly it's
like your car breaks down suddenly like
you know something happens crazy in the
kitchen the blender flies off and the
knife flies and it h breaks the window
now you got to pay for the window like
it's like all these things start
happening and it's all trying to get you
off Pace yes and when that happens I
just I want to encourage everybody to
just zoom out for a second cuz I feel
like so many people have hit that wall
where it's like is it going to be worth
it like I told myself I was going to
bring my lunch and it's just it's such a
hassle and you already want to give up
you've just got to zoom out for a moment
and go okay this is resistance and I
knew that this was going to happen this
is not a bad thing it doesn't mean that
I should stop matter of fact the way I
view it is if you're getting hit with
that it means you're really creating
friction and that's good because if you
want change you cannot change without
creating friction in your life right
you're doing something completely
different you're going on a new pathway
and there is going to be resistance so
Embrace that stop for a moment and go
okay that's what that was like now I
know that's what that was I can go
forward and don't let it stop you that's
my encouragement for the day now let's
get to the phone lines where we've got
Carrie in San Francisco
California Hi how are you thank you for
taking my call you're welcome thanks for
calling us how can we help well
essentially I would like to retire I'm
planning on retiring in October I'm a
teacher um and I'm getting nervous just
financially if I'll be able to do it so
I just wanted some reassurance I think
I'm going to be fine but I just need a
little reassurance okay so let's kind of
look at your numbers here number one um
are you working with any sort of
professional or is it just you looking
at your accounts evaluating it on your
own I do I do have um somebody who
manages is my rth and Ira my portfolio
and what are they saying to you he says
I'm totally fine okay well that's good
that gives me a little bit of but let's
kind of Let's Make sure you understand
it so how much do you have set aside in
your nest
egg um I have 350 right now okay and
what about and then I have I have
80 and well I have 80,000 and higher
yielding savings okay and that's just
cuz me I've been stockpiling um since I
paid off my house okay um I travel yes
um and I have a travel fund that's like
it's 30,000 and it's another high
yielding and that's the one I was
planning on you know when I want to
travel I could just go into there and
get it I love that and so if you were to
retire in October how what percentage
are you pulling off of your nest egg and
what is that equal to per year oh well
I'm not sure if I'll even have to pull
out any um I'm assuming I met with the
retirement people and I'll be getting
about 1,800 a month um from that I also
have another 1200 that I get monthly
from another retirement um through a
divorce okay so that's none of that is
the 350,000 that you talked about no no
that's just what I'll be getting from my
retirement through work and um yeah
that's what I'll be bringing in yeah
like if if if that 3,000 is enough for
you to live your life and do everything
you want to do and you're not I I I have
no objections your honor yeah yeah I
mean okay okay yeah it's exting it's a
big question Carrie because I don't want
to direct you wrong like it's like you
you know retiring so I do want to make
sure that you are talking to somebody
that's looking at your actual accounts
and uh the historical data what they've
done I mean like yeah they're looking at
the whole picture but for you calling us
in a two-minute radio that's a good
point yes um yeah I mean it all seems to
to pan out care youve done a really
great job and your living expenses you
don't have a mortgage um do are you do
you have anyone or anything that you're
responsible for financially is it just
you I don't okay yeah I don't so $3,000
is enough for you Carrie um plenty month
to month and you have a travel funds
over here you got $80,000
away yeah uh how much is in that divor
the the one that's paying you 1,200 the
one from the divorce you said how much
is in that what's the nest EG um I just
I'm gonna get 1,200 for Life For Life
okay yeah and then there's the 1,800 now
are you getting any Social
Security no I will be but it's minimal
you know but and I'm and I'm only six
and I'll I'll only be 60 so it's not
like I don't think I can draw on social
security for quite a while
but um yes there is some available there
and I also know I won't be paying into
my rth because that's what my guy told
me he's a carry but you'll also be get
having 800 that you pay every month for
your
R you know that you won't be paying once
you retire that's right because you're
not drawing an income like you're not
you're not working anymore now the 1,800
that you're getting what's that Nest EG
is or is that continuous as well that
that's for life as well that's do my
work is that just a pension as a teacher
yeah yes and teacher okay yeah that's
great Carrie yeah I mean from right now
all yeah that all it feels like GRE yeah
that's great congratulations that's
exciting
congratulations thank you all right good
oh I feel a little better good you
should feel great you've done
wonderfully okay great awesome yes
Carrie happy New Year thank you so much
for the call you know there's so many
people Chade that oh they want that they
want that story and and here's what I
love about Carrie too is I'm like she is
there's a level of contentment in her
did you hear that she's like I have some
money that set aside for travel yeah but
I can live on three grand I'm great I'm
great and the 350 that she saved up I'm
like that's a lot of money to stock away
throughout her life for retirement and
you know you hear people and they're
like oh I have to have X amount you know
all of this and I'm like there's just a
beauty in listening to Carrie as she
walks through those numbers and I'm like
yeah she's done it you know she did
everything right she let them take the
money out for her pension but then she
continued to put hers away in the Roth
which is what we teach um I love that
she's got the 80k saved which honestly
is above and beyond what she might need
for an emergency fund but I love that
she has it like that's wonderful
absolutely and for me I think the
biggest thing her mortgage is paid off
yes you didn't have a
mortgage bills yeah and that's why she
can be like yeah 3,000 I'm good on that
yeah I'm great I mean it's awesome
that's what people have to challenge
yourselves Francisco California I'm like
know she's in Northern California like
as a teacher y'all I mean did you just
hear all of that like yeah it's great a
teacher in Northern California like I
yeah I feel like we need to marinate on
that for a second Rachel cuz that's such
cuz I bet with her house she's close to
being an everyday millionaire 100%
didn't even ask her that we should asked
her that J ter we're going to just dream
she everyday she's an everyday
millionaire but for those of you
listening start dreaming it's January
start dreaming what would your life be
like if one day you paid your mortgage
off right most of us are paying a a
couple thousand dollars a month for our
mortgage that's the biggest line item
how would your life change this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
Jade warshaw this is Rachel Cruz to my
right we're taking your calls all
afternoon so give us a call the number
is8
825-5222 that you're aspiring to you're
probably starting to have those
difficult conversations with your spouse
you're starting to budget you're
starting to take your lunch all those
things it makes you feel some type of
way so we're here to help so give us a
call uh we've got anaise who's on the
phone line in Phoenix Arizona what's
going on
anaise hi um so my husband and I are
dual income no kids and we're looking to
have kids in like 3ish years and we just
bought a house and so we're trying to
figure out for the next three years we
know we're going to have more financial
flexibility than when we do have kids
and so we're trying to figure out
because we're young whether to focus a
lot of our attention on chipping away at
our mortgage or saving for retirement
since we live mostly off just his income
we have almost all of my income to put
somewhere awesome that's great that is
great um I think that's a great way to
be thinking because it is true when you
have kids life changes and things do get
more expensive um and so there come
comes the the question put the extra
money on the mortgage or onto retirement
so the answer that I'll give you is just
kind of filtered through the framework
that we use here at Ramsey Solutions um
how familiar are you with the baby
steps pretty familiar we have zero debt
we have six months of living expenses
saved up um so we have like all those
I'm pretty sure we have all the baby
steps done perfect okay so then it's
just really we're getting to a
technicality right so for all intents
and purposes you're on baby step four
five and six right so baby step four for
new listeners is putting 15% into
retirement baby step five is you're
putting aside some amount of money that
you decide for your kids college and
you're putting it in a non-prepaid 529
or Esa account and then baby step six is
you're also simultaneously putting extra
money on your mortgage now here's the
thing baby steps four five and six if
they all apply to you you can you you do
them
simultaneously so if are you already at
the 15% mark on your
investing yes my husband puts 15 of his
per 15% of his paycheck and I put 20% of
mine okay so you want to be at 15% for
your household that's the goal and once
you get to 15% because remember we're
doing these simultaneously anything
above 15% at this point you need to be
thinking about baby step five and baby
step six because you are saying okay now
if you want to wait until you have kids
to do baby step five yeah that's totally
fine I would
put I would not put money aside for
future children that I do not have yet
yes that's right and then for you now
you're to baby step six so the extra
money right now you're putting on baby
step six which is paying off your home
now and this is for you and anybody
listening once you pay off your home
then you can go ham on the investing
like you can start investing Way Beyond
15% that's the beauty of how this plan
works is you are going to have that
extra money to just get crazy and that's
where things like go off the reals
so my question with that would be we're
super young I'm 22 and so I have heard
the advice that investing in your
retirement younger is going to do better
and since we just got our mortgage it's
probably going to be a little while for
us to fully pay it off would you
recommend putting more than 15% because
we're so young or no matter what 15% and
then pay off the I would I would still
do it the same way because you're fine
going to be fine and you're creating
diversification which is really
important um 15% number one is so much
more than average like most people
invest right up to their match most
people do it while they have debt so the
fact that you're debt-free you're at 15%
and I'm sure by the way if you have a
match the match is not included in the
15% so if you or your husband has some
sort of your match make sure you're
still of your own money putting 15% and
then like I said with this extra money
yeah you guys are young and that's part
of the beauty of this equation for you
because not only are you going to grow
compound interest over time because you
are actively investing you're going to
have your home paid off over time it's
just going to offer you so many options
because you're going to have wealth on
two sides and then once you pay your
home off like I said you're Off to the
Races and you're just G you're just
going to be blown away by how this works
for you yeah cuz anal let me say this on
least just to paint a picture for you
yeah that 15% of your income into
retirement and then everything else goes
to the house is what I would do and
because you are so young you pay it off
early and then what's Wild is you're
going to be one of these people that
stands on the debt free scream stage and
you have your house paid off and you
guys are in your 30s and then you go and
invest like crazy because then you'll
move on to baby step seven which is save
and be you know or invest and be
extremely generous so you will then bump
up that 15% probably with investing and
do more if you guys want like you just
have so many options but having a paid
Ford house and investing 15% like that's
the ultimate goal which you guys are
working towards which you could have
which is just crazy how much do you guys
make a year I'm just curious um we make
roughly combined close to like
88 how much is your
house um our house it we have 305 on the
loan okay yeah that's I love that so
yeah you guys are GNA get this paid off
and it's going to be great and then you
can bump up uh other investing if you
want uh after that but well let's kind
of let's kind of reframe this in your
mind on a lease because I I I do think
that sometimes people view okay I've got
my retirement investing and then I've
got my house they're both Investments
yeah that's a good like they're both
investment vehicles I don't want you to
think that um a you know a 401k or a
Roth IRA investment is more important or
a better investment than a home like
there's a a reason that uh real estate
is a big choice for people to put their
money because the rate on return is very
uh you can on it you know what I'm
saying we say all the time like if you
if you're owning a property for 3 to 5
years 5 years or more you are going to
see a return like that's what we've seen
over time the same way we talk about the
S&P 500 we know like over time you can
expect you know a 10 to 12% rate of
return annualized over the course of you
know x amount of years so that's uh I
think that's really important for people
listening to understand these are both
great investment vehicles that's why we
say do them Sim simultaneously not do
this one first and and then reach over
here and do that one so that's something
worth pointing out thank you so much for
the call I like it it's a good
conversation all right and the younger
people are that are calling it's it is
it's amazing I'm like Jade like we I
feel like we've had so many calls of
young people doing this stuff early you
guys and I'm like and it's just an
encouragement to you listening out there
uh again regardless of age but man it
there is something to be said about
these principles and doing them in the
right order and and being diligent about
it it just it it in your favor always it
will yield in your favor yeah but I mean
we we do have to call out like there is
that tension between um we know like she
said like obviously the longer that
you're in the market compound interest
has a longer time to work for you and
obviously the more money you invest the
more money there's there but um it is
that tension between if you work the
plan and do it the correct way yeah like
you're you're pushing play on some
pushing pause on some things to push
play on the on other things but
ultimately like it all works out
together you know and so many people are
worried like well if I pay off my debt
then I'm waiting to invest and I know
you guys say pause investing while
you're paying off debt Jade I'm going to
miss out you know three years and I
can't stress enough to people listening
that you will make it up like the way
this is designed you will make up for
the time as long as you stick to the
plan like if you like lolly gag or if
you like take this but leave that and
you don't this is a to be worked as the
plan is written and I can't stress that
enough um if you say oh I'm working the
Dave Ramsey plan but you're just you
know messing around with this debt and
kind of being willy-nilly on it and it
takes you six years yeah you miss out on
retirement that's right that's right so
you got to walk it the way it goes you
know if you say oh like I talked to
somebody the other day they're like oh
Jade I'm working the Ramsey plan I'm not
investing yet but I just really want to
get my house paid off y I'm like listen
I'm glad you want to get your house paid
off but you need to be investing so
follow the plan as written if you want
the results that we're always talking
about yeah there's an order yeah it's
the order for the reason but um but yeah
like annaise who just called I'm like
she's at the perfect position to do it
and it's going to be amazing we're debt
and money doesn't have to be the thing
that controls you that you really do
control it so being proactive in that
sense it's great I love that and then I
always like to remind people who think
that it's too late or it's too late to
start or maybe there's no hope I'm like
listen look at look at me right here I
start investing till my 30s and I'm
blown away like I'm Blown Away by the
numbers I see by just being diligent and
working the plan so if you're out there
you feel like you got a late start it's
not too late just keep doing what you
know to do and in the right time you
will reap a harvest if you don't give up
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
you are listening to the ramsy show
thank you for listening I am your host
Jade warsh joined by Rachel Cruz we've
been taking your calls and now we've got
the scripture and quote of the day James
1:17 says every good and perfect gift is
from above coming down from the father
of heavenly lights who does not change
like shifting Shadows love that one of
my favorite verses and uh our quote of
the day I feel like you should read this
Rachel because you're you're a true
Swifty I feel like Taylor Swift quote no
matter what happens in life be good to
people being good to people is a Wonder
ful Legacy to leave behind T Swift see
there you go what a what a gal what a
gal she was uh at the chief's game
handing out $100 bills to the staff and
everyone yes that's pretty awesome she
like crazy she like tipped insane
bonuses to all of her yep truck drivers
and stuff for her tour and yeah I'm
about that life I believe I believe
she's generous I you know what I I'm
going to say in front of all the world
uh I think I need to understand more
about Taylor I've never been on the the
Tes Swift
oh come on I'll I got to get with the
times I'll share my seat with you while
trying it's a it's a fun ride yeah help
me get on because I I don't I haven't I
don't get it and I need to get it cuz I
feel like I'm no I think she just speaks
what we've all felt in life is that what
it is it's her song I think it's her
well like her songwriting like she just
she sings I should say yes and writes I
think just what we all I don't know I'm
a I'm a I'm a 14-year-old at heart
what's your faite what's your favorite
t- Swift song oh gosh Jade just hit me
with one shoot give me a few notes um
I'm not going to I'm just
kidding that's going to be my the lover
album might be my favorite that's going
to be my question to all the callers
moving forward all right let's go to
Peter and Manchester New Hampshire
what's going on Peter hey thanks for
taking the call um so I am about
9,920 in credit card debt and9,9 or1
19,6 $
3887 in student loan debt okay for a
combined total of around
$30,000 plus or minus that's right a
little under that um and so I was
wanting to know how can I get out of
debt and then what should I do after I'm
out of debt I have no emergency fund so
I don't know where to start good um well
you came to the right place I'm happy
that you're here um okay so let's start
by getting some particulars how much do
you earn every
month what do you take home about
$874 after taxes I'm a student employee
at my University I currently attend okay
um what year of college are you in I'm a
sophomore okay sore okay so so you're in
school
full-time yes if I wasn't I wouldn't be
able to stay in the housing and since my
parents passed away when I was 11 years
old I'd be homeless on streets go goet
oh I'm so sorry that's tough oh goodness
how old are you now I'm making it I'm 21
years old Wow way to go wow so you went
through college I just want to make sure
I get this are you still are you still a
student there or you're you're working
there and living there you're still a
student I'm still a student sophore okay
sophomore oh I'm sorry I hear you okay
so okay um I want to address two sides
of this so I get the feeling of I
understand being in college and being a
debt because that was me
um however I I don't want you to get too
hung up on this because your student
loan is technically technically not due
yet right it becomes due uh six months
after you graduate um at least it used
to I think that's still accurate um it's
still in so while you're a student U my
understanding is per FASA which it's all
all of them are Federal loans so I won't
have to go into repayment until six
months after I graduate scho and I'm
guessing there subsidized so they're not
um they're not gaining interest right
now um yep I do have two
unsubsidized loans but Max interest on
on both around
5.38% so um yeah and I I know that it
sucks that it's acre interest on the two
unsubsidized loans but I wouldn't let
that get to me right now now your credit
cards you don't want those to go into
default so I would work to make sure I'm
paying minimum payments on those if you
can get a little extra that's fine but
my main Focus for you is focusing on
school and focusing on graduating
without any more debt is that fair
enough yes and Peter can I ask what
caused all the credit card debt so I
needed I was a little worried I wasn't
going to be able to afford College
anymore so I kind of panicked and
purchased a bunch of emergency supplies
in case I ended up on the streets again
um and so that's the majority of the
debt I also purchased a
bicycle to get to and from a job site
when I was homeless after I left the
Marine Corps after I was medically
discharged um I was able to use a
bike to go to and from my campsite and
my job okay so um I was kind of planning
ahead and I planed too far ahead okay
which
is understandable yeah yeah yeah totally
but yeah with Jade what what she was
saying though I think is is key we don't
want to obviously go deeper into that
and we don't want to default in that and
so um is there any other time
Peter um that you can look at throughout
your week that maybe you could do um one
more thing on the side to bring in some
income currently I'm also in Army Roc at
my college so I just got a medical
waiver approved to reinlist or rejoin
the military um okay and so in about
four months or so I'll be getting an RC
stien um in addition to a scholarship
that should actually reduce the overall
cost of my um overall college experience
by about half because I'll no longer
have to account for room and board so um
yeah it's really good and then in
addition to getting the
$420 monthly stiping from the United
States Army I'll also be um working an
additional oncampus job that pays around
177 an hour okay um how many hours for
about 20 hours a week and then my
current job I work that Nets me after
taxes
$874 per month um is a work study job so
it ISS a manatory required minimum of
$12 an hour for a maximum of 20 hours a
week okay so here's the equation we're
trying to solve for I like that you're
getting into it you're finding money the
equation we've got to solve for is can
you pay for tuition in cash how much
does it cost because I don't want you I
mean you've got
$1,638 of student loans and my guess is
that's because you've gotten student
loans for each semester thus far so
we've got to look at going forward are
you able to make this work and what does
it look like going forward does that
make sense yep so what what what do you
need to um how much does school cost so
my current semester I was I was looking
over my bill it's around
$25,000 per semester 25,000 per semester
where are you going to school Peter I'm
going to Southern Hampshire
University okay is that a is it public
private I don't know it's uh I believe
it's privateness okay private nonprofit
though that feels expensive um it's also
because I'm an out of Stater so I I I
was in DC but unfortunately it was
really unsafe for me to continue living
in DC while I was heless I was involved
I was shocked so um I didn't feel safe
going to school or living in Washington
DC anymore okay and okay
um you how old are you again tell me
your age again um 21 21 years old
okay and what's your degree going to be
in it's going to be Injustice studies
with a minor in
sociology I'm going to say something
difficult um and it just it just is what
it
is you're choosing an expensive route
here for school you're at a private
university and you're at an out of state
private university um and that's you
still have two and a half years left and
you've got two and a half years left and
I don't like that for you because with
the money that you said I don't see a
pathway for you to pay for this so
something's going to have to change and
I know that you've suffered a trauma so
it's very hard for me to sit here and be
the one to say Hey listen go back to DC
um I'll be honest with you if you're in
DC I don't know like can you go to any
school in in Mar can you get into
Maryland or can you get into Virginia
does it count because I'm obviously
District of Columbia is a small area so
are there the do the surrounding states
count at all you need to really look
into this and start evaluating your
options is there anything you can do is
it an online school is there something
you can do that you can get that degree
go slowly you cannot go into any more
debt that's got to be off the table I
know you've been through a lot but we
got to start thinking about this this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show